bienvenidos a la serie de france 24 soy
marina sardiña y junto con mi compañero
luís muñoz hemos realizado esta serie
especial de reportajes dedicados al
quinto aniversario de la firma de los
acuerdos de paz entre el estado
colombiano y la estricta guerrilla de
las farc recorrimos parte del territorio
colombiano para conocer cómo va la paz
tras la reincorporación a la vida civil
de la que fue la mayor guerrilla de
américa latina' nuestra primera parada
es en el departamento de bolívar donde
estuvo junto a juan carlos zapata allí
vimos cómo está la situación con las
víctimas del conflicto armado de la mano
de irle y velasco sobreviviente de la
masacre del salado
18 de febrero de 2000 me mataron pero
como así que me mataron entonces quien
está escribiendo estas líneas yo yo que
sigo viva
[Música]
con ese recuerdo también hay muchas
preguntas que me hago a diario y es
porque a mí
no entiendo por qué me pasó todo eso no
entiendo
porque ya tantos hombres que me
violentaron
harley velasco vivió en primera persona
la masacre de el salado una de las
peores matanzas paramilitar en la
historia de colombia acusadas de
pertenecer a la guerrilla más de 60
personas fueron asesinadas miles
tuvieron que salir desplazadas y más de
20 fueron abusadas sexualmente
ridley tenía 14 años
más de 400 paramilitares llevaron el
horror hasta las últimas consecuencias
tras cada asesinato 2 redoblaban
tambores yo vi asesinar aquí en esta
cancha a 10 personas la conté casi 20
años después de la masacre en 2020 la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos ordenó medidas cautelares de
protección para ley
hoy vuelve al salado su pueblo después
de siete meses
su destino habitual de desplazamiento ha
sido carmen de bolívar entre la
cordillera de los andes y el mar caribe
y a 20 minutos del salado ying ley
intentó suicidarse dos veces tras su
violación pero con 17 años encontró un
propósito y desde entonces ha liderado
procesos de acompañamiento en su casa de
carmen de bolívar se encuentra la sede
de su asociación mujeres sembrando vida
esto que tenemos acá es el monitor de
las cámaras de seguridad que tiene pero
su labor de denuncia de la violencia
sexual no gusta a los victimarios
sigues en el territorio te damos dos
días para que salgas tapa y web
lesbiana somos el clan del golfo
presente las amenazas han llevado a ir
ley a cartagena de indias han más de dos
horas de su casa sólo sabe para ir a
visitar a su hermana esta fue condenada
por presuntamente enviar amenazas a ir
ley para no perder la protección del
estado
la familia de anuncia un montaje
judicial
harley le lleva el almuerzo a todos los
días y cada día habla con ella por una
rendija
con
mucha tristeza de lo de las peores cosas
que me ha pasado en la vida ha sido esto
más de 13 mil combatientes dejaron las
armas en 2016 el pacto incluye un pago
para garantizar la reintegración a la
vida civil de cada uno de los
desmovilizados con ese dinero surgieron
distintos proyectos individuales y
colectivos junto a daniel tapia fuimos a
la casa de la paz un lugar de encuentro
entre combatientes y víctimas
alexander monroy y es un firmante de paz
el acuerdo de 2016 entre la guerrilla de
las farc y el estado colombiano le dio
la oportunidad de iniciar junto a otros
no ex combatientes una marca de cerveza
artesana la trocha lo hicieron con los
cerca de dos mil dólares que les entregó
el estado al desmovilizarse en la casa
de la paz un espacio cultural en el
centro de bogotá tienen una micro
procesadora alexander está gasificando
la cerveza para el fin de semana
vamos a este espacio la casa nosotros
decimos acá cabe todo el mundo y es
permitido pensar distinto y no hay
necesidad de matarlos por eso digamos
como el sueño que nosotros tratamos de
construir aquí
tanto alexander lidera el proyecto doris
suárez que presume de su cerveza la
trocha es muy refrescante
porque no es como estas empresas
industriales
es cierto que no hemos lancha te puedes
tomar un pentágono borracho estate
antona y muy sabroso
[Música]
librería tienda y exposiciones de
fotografía la casa de la paz es un lugar
de encuentro pese a sentirse abandonados
por el estado más de 280 ex combatientes
han sido asesinados desde la firma dos
meses complicados el compromiso si es
nuestro otro yo sigo empeñado en la
palabra y comprometido con la paz pero
pues tienes fue un acuerdo de dos partes
además de excombatientes la casa de la
paz alberga otros espacios que desde la
unión de costurero que le hicieron una
comisión de la verdad hace muy poco
cierto como éste para víctimas donde
ésta virgelina chará que ver con esta
pandemia en su espacio de costura por la
verdad y la memoria entre sus distintos
proyectos destaca este libro sobre la
pandemia estar aquí es cambiar eso de
imaginario de mucha gente que cree que
porque estamos
víctimas y es combatiente entonces nos
vamos a agarrar a puño voy a decirle a
la gente que hace imaginario está
equivocado un espacio de reconciliación
que parte de la trocha porque como ellos
mismos dicen nada mejor que una cerveza
para poder compartir
con los acuerdos de paz muchos
campesinos vieron la oportunidad de
salir de la ilegalidad gracias al
programa nacional de sustitución de
cultivos de uso ilícito cinco años más
tarde hablan de incumplimiento desde el
campo de coca en el calamar guaviare
junto a benjamin el mar vimos la
realidad que sufren estos campesinos
cocaleros
yo soy el propietario de este cultivo no
me quise acoger al programa penis porque
vi que no era un programa muy viable ni
muy satisfactorio viendo de que ya en
otras zonas donde se implementó el tenis
fue un fracaso y un total incumplimiento
con los acuerdos de paz de 2016 unas 99
mil familias se inscribieron al programa
nacional de sustitución de cultivos de
uso ilícito open y para erradicar
voluntariamente las plantaciones a
cambio de subsidios james murillo líder
comunal del municipio de calamar en el
departamento colombiano del guaviare no
aceptó y desde hace 20 años sostiene a
su familia gracias al cultivo de coca
luís eduardo vaca es cocaleros y se unió
pero cinco años después se siente
engañado muchas familias nos acogimos a
este tema
pensando que era un
algo bueno para nosotros como campesinos
y fue todo un fracaso el gobierno nos
incumplió el trabajo de los campesinos
va desde las plantaciones hasta la
producción de pasta base de coca
convertida en cocaína por los
narcotraficantes así surgió una economía
ilícita que permite a los locales
subsistir durante el conflicto armado
ante el abandono estatal y el gobierno
decía que no puede invertir en estas
zonas porque estaba la guerrilla de las
farc hoy en día tienen unos acuerdos de
paz y al igual el gobierno aquí no no
invierte sin infraestructura vías ni
servicios dignos la sustitución de coca
no fue como se esperaba sólo el 2 por
ciento de los proyectos productivos
funcionan muchos los cocaleros se
encontraron en la ganadería una
alternativa pero ha incrementado el
ritmo de deforestación en esta región
amazónica tumbar bosque y vender pasto
para el ganado es el negocio más
rentable en la zona no la ganaría fue
una de las cosas que el mismo gobierno
nos incentivo a nosotros para que
dejáramos la coca y hoy en día al ver el
foco de borde estación no es así
pero es al paso que vamos nos va a tocar
volver a sembrar otra vez coca edílson
pinto se las ingenió cuando vio que la
ayuda del estado no funcionaba cambiando
la coca por el turismo reconozcan que
estará la realidad que está la economía
hace un poco años que se vio acá en el
departamento no sólo les voy a decir en
otros departamentos en su finca mantiene
el laboratorio donde elaboraba la base
de coca aquí muestra los químicos que
lleva esta pasta eso lo que hay que
fundir a la sociedad si dale a conocer
porque hay gente que consume pero no
sabe que lo que están consumiendo su
vida de un giro y ya no teme el sonido
de las avionetas militares que lanzaban
glifosato para erradicar forzosamente
los cultivos de una presión avión nada
un soft a una preocupación pues era como
una terapia o sea no se puede ver como
tranquilo pese a todos los esfuerzos los
cultivos de coca colombia aumentaron un
7% en el último año según la onu
mientras el eslabón más empobrecido en
el negocio de la droga los campesinos
continúa sufriendo todas las violencias
en sus territorios
en colombia las comunidades indígenas
continúan siendo unas de las más
afectadas por la guerra así es luís
están resistiendo a través de la
recuperación pacífica de sus territorios
ancestrales con benjamin y marc
accedemos a un resguardo indígena me
saquen el cauca donde el conflicto se
sigue enseñando contra sus líderes y
jóvenes
tuve sus disparos mi hermana de que hizo
así así como que abrazar y se cayó y
cayó la cabecita sede para acá bueno yo
le digo nos haría me escuchas yo le digo
que aparecía la cara si me escucha
con suspiros 10.000 se quedó defender el
pozo con el que su familia regaba los
cultivos de café le costó la vida a la
lideresa indígena misa cna zaira
calambás ese mismo agua la usaban grupos
armados para irrigar cultivos ilícitos
de coca su sentencia de muerte entre
páramos atravesado por el río piendamó
está el resguardo misak de guambía pero
velasco su gobernador explica los
motivos del incremento de la violencia
líderes sociales que tienen que ver con
primero pues con la puesta en marcha de
las agendas de los territorios con las
agendas de de cumplimiento el acuerdo de
paz y en especial con los
incumplimientos históricos de que ha
hecho el gobierno desde la firma de los
acuerdos de paz en 2016 1260 líderes
sociales han sido asesinados en colombia
según la ong indepa en el cauca el 50,9
por ciento de los fallecidos serán
indígenas las poblaciones étnicas cada
vez más
están siendo desplazadas en nuestros
últimos cinco años la incrementación del
conflicto armado por diversos actores
sea la del estado de la guerrilla y
otros actores no identificados pues se
están concentrando en inmediaciones o
dentro de los territorios indígenas o
campesinos la recuperación pacífica del
territorio ancestral es su forma de
resistencia de la estrechez de tierra
debido al incumplimiento de la reforma
rural integral y el fondo de tierras
destinadas a su reparación con tan sólo
el 33% de implementado vamos a hacer la
reforma agraria desde los territorios
entonces para que nuestros jóvenes no se
caigan por ejemplo los jóvenes han ido a
raspar coca a procesar coca bueno por
falta oportunidades en el conflicto
armado sigue haciendo mella en la
juventud del campo colombiano luz dary
maestra y secretaria del resguardo habla
de reclutamiento no hay como ese apoyo
en la parte agraria y por lo mismo pues
los jóvenes nuestras mujeres
pues buscan otras otras otras formas de
resistir y es ahí donde donde pues están
estaba bien el conflicto armado vienen
grupos armados pues que les prometen o
les dicen que por aquí es el camino y se
los van llevando a la paz desde la
cosmovisión de los indígenas pasa por el
respeto a la vida y la tierra algo
todavía lejano en colombia
de los acuerdos de paz surgió el sistema
integral para la paz donde destaca la
unidad de búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas en su paso la vida civil
un grupo de excombatientes formó una
comisión de búsqueda junto a juan carlos
zapata conocimos la labor de la unidad
del oriente de colombia y mi niña
de 12 años
se desapareció
mileidy yadira santa ana laura piensa
muchas veces que lo vivido forma parte
de una pesadilla cuatro hijos un marido
y un hermano están desaparecidos otro
hijo de 11 años fue asesinado lo mataron
a él el 8 yo nos de la vida porque se
ensañó de esta manera conmigo si yo no
le hice mal a ninguno y si mi familia
hizo algo porque tuve que pagar yo
esto es duro en algunos dos hijos
muy fortalecida
javits a dirige la comisión de búsqueda
de desaparecidos componente farc del
oriente de colombia y que vamos a luchar
incansablemente por encontrarlo ese es
nuestro lema
encontrarlos entonces este es para
muchos ex combatientes como laura el
único lugar al que pueden dirigirse para
reclamar a sus desaparecidos algo
imposible antes de los acuerdos de paz
de 2016 entre el gobierno y la guerrilla
de las farc porque yo nunca denuncie
nunca nada de ya la deriva todo así de
miedo que porque de pronto me mato bueno
a dicha lidera la búsqueda desde este
espacio de reincorporación de firmantes
de paz conocido como mariana páez y
ubicado en mesetas meta han documentado
más de 800 casos que permitieron a la
unidad de búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas y el comité internacional
de la cruz roja a ubicar a más de 100
desaparecidos
la comisión de la verdad cuenta más de
100.000 desapariciones forzadas por el
conflicto un crimen de lesa humanidad
los ex combatientes tratan de encontrar
a todas las víctimas del conflicto
los testimonios anónimos de excompañeros
una forma de reparación todos son
necesarios buscarlo porque su familia lo
está requiriendo su familia está
sufriendo la ausencia los los ha matado
en vida ya dichas tuvo 30 años en la
guerrilla donde llegó a ser comandante
todavía guardar recuerdos como su diario
escrito en la cárcel tras ser detenida
en un bombardeo donde perdió a su pareja
con la nueva independencia nuestra
patria liberar y sentar un precedente
por toda la eternidad y aritz a tiene un
hermano desaparecido después de toda una
vida armada en selvas como esta vuelve
ahora en su misión de búsqueda con una
nueva convicción el firme compromiso con
la paz
en 2016 el ex presidente juan manuel
santos dijo que en 2021 colombia estaría
libre de minas antipersona y aunque no
se ha cumplido el desminado avanza
humanicemos dh es la primera
organización de desminadores formada
íntegramente por ex combatientes con
aurora ballut presenciamos una de sus
operaciones
cuénteme don luís que por acá que acabo
encontrar un grupo de ex combatientes de
las extintas farc ha encontrado un
artefacto pero podemos decir que que
puede ser una una mina antipersonal un
campesino les había avisado de que en su
predio podría haber explosivos de la
guerra y no le fuimos junto a sus
compañeros juan carlos prepara una
barricada que reduzca el daño
medioambiental
después mediante una barra de acero van
a disparar contra el artefacto
listo vámonos
te hacen acá para que no para evitar
riesgos los desminadores se esconden
para todas la unidades y tiene el fuego
en un minuto
un riesgo donde una persona después se
puede un animal se puede accidental lo
estamos quitando pues por eso estos
disparos son mejores que lo que hacíamos
antes
fuego en el área
decíamos que se crea contenedor será no
no lo haya visto alguna vez pero para
hacer eso sin seguir utilizaban como
contenedores de para ser para fabricar
minas humanicemos es el resultado de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno y la
guerrilla de las farc de 2016 aunque su
operación no empezó hasta 2020 reciben
financiación del fondo europeo para la
paz y su actividad está monitoreada por
un más el servicio de acción contra las
minas de las naciones unidas tiene más
de 100 trabajadores y es la primera
organización de desminado del mundo
formada íntegramente por desminadores
firmantes de paz cada día se desplazan a
los remotos lugares que ocupaban cuando
eran combatientes de artefactos que
germán balanta es gerente de terreno en
las farc era comandante la
reincorporación trata de mantener las
estructuras anteriores con un fin muy
diferente fuimos un actor del conflicto
y que también colocamos minas y hoy la
estamos retirando
la vuelta a la vida civil ha significado
una nueva oportunidad a la chica
cómo estás
[Música]
yo muy feliz en esta vida porque ya soy
una más con mi familia pero el impacto
del desminado también llega a las
comunidades en colombia cada día hay más
de una víctima por minas antipersonal
el área que se despejó el verdader ya
está volviendo a un resguardo de los
indígenas embera chamí apenas un mes
antes devolvieron el territorio libre de
minas podemos caminar en este es por
esta área es muy grato saber eso de
parte de ustedes que también agradecidos
y nosotros es también un desminado que
permite que los niños hoy puedan volver
a pisar los caminos de un futuro que
sueñan que sea de paz
con esto llegamos al final de nuestra
serie especial por los acuerdos de paz a
las dificultades de su implementación la
paz avance en colombia pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]